wait what I I missed the whole first
part can you suck on each other's
nipples at the same time yeah answer I
mean yes or no yeah yeah
let's try
[Music]
all right we got somebody on the Discord
you guys might already know him he's got
a lot of suggestions all the time his
name is Apple Apple
757 he had a really good question he
wanted to know back when um you're in
high school what was your go-to date
spot
[Music]
um
I really like miniature golfing
yeah that's really cute yeah I like
miniature golfing because um I feel like
when you're moving around you're having
fun and you're like kind of like
slightly competitive having to uh in
your planet game it's more more chances
to like be yourself and have a good time
I don't really like movies like I feel
like movies was like after you got to
know them then you go go enjoy a movie
but it's like if you're like first time
going on a date like
it's all [__] loud and [__] you did
movies all wrong that's where you kiss
and and actually get to do all that but
that's your first date so you we go
there like and you start making it
[Laughter]
Joe said we're doing the song
you said we shouldn't watched the movie
at all yeah I know I barely know you but
let's just [__] right now I mean that
was the thing though like you go to
scary movies scary and she's like oh my
God and you're like I'll protect you
yeah yeah you guys remember Borders
bookstores yeah so that was your first
take no no he left immediately
let's go to the library Bay no it's kind
of a fire date though
has been playing there at night they got
a cafe you can just sit down and talk
and chill and it smells good in there it
smells like books and you can like walk
around it's like stuff to do while
you're talking and walking yeah
oh the beaches though the beach is a
banger for me it was it was like uh the
drop us off at the mall yeah and then
because then there's like a lot of
things you could do mall is great
[__] Wetzel Pretzel you could go to
like
be like girl I got you you don't do the
pretzel in front of you hey make that
bigger you know you you go to Cinnabon
and you share one you get two forks and
[__] you know yeah you could go to an
arcade and a movie you just got options
it's like you got whatever and you could
just [__] window shop and be like if
I was a millionaire I would buy that you
know
yeah and then like you talk about the
[__] that you like you know yeah I would
I think the mall was the best because it
just had variety your Mac invoice always
sounds like Scat Jazz that's cool oh if
I was a millionaire
[Laughter]
I I think my youth I was always I like
to date up because I like like older
girls right okay age-wise yeah because
like they dressed cooler like so if I
was like in junior high I wanted a high
school group wasn't in high school I
wanted a college girl right or like
whatever and then so damn you're in a
man bro I always because I just it just
they look more like a woman 20 year old
girls my age like if I'm in seventh
grade like their mom still dresses them
and [__] and then whatever right like
yeah and then the ones that are cute or
maybe like taken or whatever see look at
other girls and [__] yeah and it's so
like and in high school let's say like
you get dropped off at the at the mall
and then they're like oh they're sisters
with them and they're like it's a double
day or whatever but I've always been in
situations where like they were way more
forward than I was ready to be and then
so like I'm just trying to be cool like
I Kissed before and I'm like I don't
know what the [__] I'm doing
we're not being kissed awkward Asian boy
an older female like well older female
be like a year older oh okay because I
was thinking like what if she was like
like she's a 40 year old yeah yeah I
think because you're taught to be have
manners and be shy and you're like maybe
a lot of like Asian movies or even like
our moms always like you want to be a
gentleman and all that right so that's
like so instilled so you never want to
make the first move I remember like one
of the first kisses I had I was hanging
out with this chick
and then she was like and I'm like so
oblivious because like you you know what
she's talking about but you also want to
be a gentleman so I remember she was
like
what would you do if like the lights
were off right now on your and both of
our eyes were closed and I'm like well
the lights are on you know
idiot
I don't know like
what would you do what would you do if
the lights were off and our eyes were
closed and she came over and kissed me
and then I was like oh you push her [__]
but the lights are on but then you give
in right but then it was just like
there's that tension in the room and
you're trying to like
you're trying to like not be a pervert
at the same time and then you're like
but she's clearly painting a scenario
and then you're like oh my God my ears
looking so hot right
my tears
bro my [__] blood pressure is crazy
because it might not be all like I'm
like I'm like getting kissed right and
I'm like I didn't even ask you to be my
girlfriend yet yeah and I'm already
getting a kid like we're skipping
instead it felt like I was losing my
virginity before marriage I need to buy
you a teddy bear or something I'm like
you're kissing me yeah what the [__]
yeah I don't even know your locker
combination
that is so that is true though we're
skipping way too many steps it's so
weird that we had the stance of like we
had the stance of being on the other
side like on the playing defense or
something for real why why is that quite
goalie dude because then you I don't
know you just want to be like this
[__] pervert Yeah you don't want to
be a [__] yeah I mean like I'll make the
first move
you say that you used to make the first
move usually like with dating and stuff
not when I was younger not when you're
younger you didn't run into idiots like
us that were just like oh I had this guy
who was in so I was on the dance team in
high school and this guy was on band and
we would meet each other because we
would dance for the football team and so
the band would be there but this guy was
just super oh my God I feel so bad
you're just so awkward and so shy and
just just a kind of weird but you like
them look not at all
um
it was like he he just like walk Acro SS
from me hey
like walk away like this was super
awkward I'm like all right like he's
playing hard again yeah so on on
Valentine's Day he brought this like
massive teddy bear like it's like human
size like very inconvenient yeah right
very inconvenient you have to hold it
the whole day really so like he he walks
in here he gives it to me and I can't
even see who's giving it to me because
it's so big yeah
oh my God okay and then I just I'm
holding this thing and my friend comes
up to me she's like what if there's like
cameras in the eyes or something I was
like the [__] cameras yeah I was just
like where am I gonna put this thing
like so he just gives it to you and runs
away yeah he's just like happy about his
day and gives it to me and this is
massive like with teddy bear with no
like nothing no dialogue no nothing just
sometimes I'm just here guys are so
[__] weird and I was just like okay
what the [__] am I gonna do with this
like this thing is like massive I'm
carrying like a like a a huge like human
being almost must have really loved you
[Laughter]
you should reach out and then so I went
to like my my drama class and I went to
my teacher I'm like can I just like
leave this here oh no I don't know where
to [__] put this like did you ever
get to talk to him you guys ever date or
anything no no that was it oh no no
it became like extra awkward after that
because you didn't talk to him and he
didn't talk to you and it just got worse
but that's what weird ass movement
you're not already kind of there yeah it
was just like zero to a hundred he's the
kind of guy that tries to buy love
like that's the that's the start of it
like I don't know how to talk to women
and then I'm just gonna start buying her
jewelry yeah yeah but you did them a
solid by rejecting it so now he knows oh
buying things won't get me love so now
he's gonna no he's gonna go the teddy
bear wasn't big enough
another one I should get her an
engagement ring like why didn't you just
trap me like this size yeah yeah like
why did it have to be like a full-size
table Yeah because the big she wanted to
wow you maybe he won it at a carnival
what's something that a guy did of that
nature that actually was a good thing
that one though like it was nice that
was a banger it was a bigger teddy bear
what was a good opener
they both walk down the hall at the same
time with both of their bears
for my love
um now there's a guy in high school we
didn't have any classes together but we
both thought we like were attractive and
in between walking to our classes we had
the same path we would hand notes to
each other
so how did it start did he just hand you
a note yeah and it was funny it was a
funny note and he like draw and stuff
and he was actually a good artist and I
was like all right cool so that became
like a thing to a point where we had
like a whole binder of just like notes
but then but the I think the key was you
were already attracted you guys were
attracted right yeah yeah and then it
started with him giving you a note
whereas like he didn't build any rapport
with you he just brought you a teddy
bear I mean it helps yeah that he was
attractive oh of course but like what if
the note was weird right he could have
struck out he could have struck out one
of those do you open it up and he's like
I've been watching you oh he's like I
put lipstick on my [__] and I kissed
it
[Laughter]
[Music]
what up guys this episode is brought to
you by looming and if you're not
familiar with what Lumi is it is a total
all body deodorant and in my opinion
it's very revolutionary because it's
developed by a doctor OB GYN to be exact
so she used to study the vaginas in case
you don't know what OB GYN is and they
also deliver babies but back to the
vaginas a lot of people were
misdiagnosing where this Bo is coming
from so she created a deodorant that
uses mandelic acid which is a
preventative measure it's not like oh
this smells good so let's cover up the
stinky smell it gets to the bottom of it
and you can use it everywhere under boob
five but your poop pole your pee hole
everywhere and it doesn't matter if
you're a guy or girl or anything like
that so it's pretty amazing and it works
up to 72 hours for me I'm a scientist so
I had to test it out I put on my PP
because sometimes my pee pee is stinky
and then it wasn't stinky Nomo so it
works really good I didn't test if it
was 72 hours I just did it for one day
so if you're looking for something to
not cover up the stinky but make sure
everything smells good or fresh from the
source with the mandelic acid give Lumi
a try and which is why the Lumi starter
pack is perfect for new customers and it
comes with a solid Stick deodorant cream
tube deodorant two free products of your
choice like mini body wash and deodorant
wipes and free shipping as a special
offer for listeners new customers get
five dollars off a Lumi starter pack
with the code OTR at lumide.com that
equates to over 40 of your starter pack
when you visit Lumi deodorant.com and
use the code OTR
[Laughter]
did you have an actual like boyfriend in
high school that went to your school
while you're there yeah how was that
um he was the guy lost my virginity to
oh
prep moving
yeah that's nice yeah was he white no
nice good yeah good good no same race
stuff yeah this is California was it
white yes
that's nice what happened to him
um like till this day yeah like what
made it not what made it branch
I think uh I think I just kind of
separated from him like we lost interest
or I lost interest
while you were still going to the same
school
yeah okay so he had to see you every day
and go
yeah yeah that age bro you're
heartbroken oh that affects your hold
do my homework yeah yeah I get focused
not that I was gonna do it anyways I'm
not going to college he didn't go to
college dude that's [__] up what's the
point of algebra She's Not Gonna Love Me
Anymore is he still following you on
stuff
um
I haven't talked to him since high
school find him let's follow him right
now on your phone but he was so sweet
like come to my dance performances and
next to my mom have good conversations
with her damn he was a sweet guy
Stephanie was so boring right cool guys
sweet is boring
what did you feel like uh you lost
interest
no too much punches
no damn it two Filipino you're right
about here I need you here's a little
going crazy did he get too bored and too
predictable or something do you like you
too much was that what it was one
question at the time no answer all in
one answer like we're trying to fix it
no I think there's a shot there's a shot
Colleen I don't I don't remember I think
I remember all my breakups I understand
I understood why it didn't work out
definitely yeah I don't remember all of
them retrospected only some of the
biggest the biggest impact ones I think
I had like an interest in somebody else
like I think it was one of those
situations that's the thing yeah I mean
when you're young you'd like five people
at once yeah I mean I mean it was like
freshman to sophomore year of high
school oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
baby time it's a young laugh yeah that's
amazing you know what's crazy is this
was 1997 and My First Girlfriend took me
on a date to get boba and in 97 wow
you're at the Tapioca Express that's
when it was like only a quickly and I
never even heard of it at all and she's
like she goes China it's Boba and I
remember trying going ew really I was
like this is sick I remember my first
boba
We're not gonna make it baby
this is on the Rocks
nah dude my first was a mango slush with
Boba oh yeah you know how they use
it it was slushies yeah there's all
kinds of weirdest fruit [__] which I
hate rainbow jelly [__] out of here you
know yeah so that's why we didn't work
out
she had bad taste of food
um there were all kinds of stuff like
like for First Dates like it would just
be like oh let's go hang out the park
real quick and just share a joint yeah
yeah or David Dave and Busters was like
a thing oh damn it mushrooms but you
know what I forgot about how good the
miniature golf thing is that's such a
good that's already like a fun
environment you can still talk yeah and
you see other couples so it makes the
like like that warmth warms you guys up
you know yeah we did a lot of group
dating or bowling
I didn't I didn't do as much like
one-on-one dating and I think it's
because the parents thing yeah like it's
like if you have a group together it's
like oh this let's all just get dropped
off at miniature golf or like Knott's
Berry Farm or whatever and then and then
you know you cover for each other and
it's like I'm just going with my friends
what about when they first started
driving
that was 17 18 I mean by that time I'm
already like sexually active and wild
like an adult you know so like
wave
I was already sexually active
I already had a long like a like a like
a girlfriend and NorCal yeah you had a
list yeah that basically ran away with
me and yeah and she was like 19. and she
ran away yeah and then I picked her up
she goes I don't want to be home anymore
I'm like [__] it and then so we drove
off I did that yeah that's right and
then so I then I turned like 18 and she
was like 20 and then we just stayed at
my house
and I was like see that's the perks of
being the latchkey kid man yeah like
pretty much have your own house yeah
yeah kids can't do that now everyone's
working from home dude
like when you were younger you weren't
really like going on like actual dates
it was just like you know it wasn't like
oh meet me at this time because you
couldn't drive yet it was hard because
you didn't have the guts to call it a
date sometimes either yeah you were like
hey you want to go here but to say like
would you like to go on a date like
verbatim was tough I never did that but
when I look back I'm like oh that
totally was a date because it's just you
and this one girl or whatever but you're
like just like let's just meet up and
hang out but then the way you hang out
and how you're like liking each other it
becomes a day but you just don't call it
that bro anything where you can play
games like Busters or miniature golf
well you can start flirt messing them up
when they're trying to take their shot
and before you know it you're like
[Music]
oh my God
you're talking about a panty Chopper
I remember eighth or ninth grade right I
did the whole like I did the whole um
any girls coming at it like that oh my
gosh
sorry sorry so like so like around that
age eighth or ninth grade that we I hung
out a lot with this girl and then like
she was like oh you were so like good
friends and I'm like I know in my head
we're dating you know like yeah cause
like
you think
that you're actually building romance
but in her mind it's a platonic
friendship and then like I like and then
I was like finally like yeah I'm gonna
[__] pour my heart out to her and
[__] and then she's like
France
and I'm all like
dating so many times she was at your
house recently I feel like that's
happened to you
but then like I was like
oh why I thought we were like I thought
we were like gonna get married and [__]
and then like I was like thinking like
why did this happen that's tough you
know that goes both ways too because I
was hanging out with this chick and we
were hanging out all the time but I
didn't know that she had liked me and I
thought all of our Hangouts were like oh
yeah we're just friends you got it my
boy
can where she thought we were a thing
and I was like oh but did you did you
put your thing in her things oh I didn't
you dirty boy dude but it happens both
ways where like the guy's completely
oblivious and you really think it's just
friend hangout well I I mean like the
older you get it's like if she's not
touching you you're probably not
together right but when you're in eighth
grade
you can be together and not touch each
other or kiss you're right you're right
cause like dude I would I would have a
girlfriend at like fourth grade and [__]
and then we're like we we don't even
[__] kiss or touch we're just like
that's my girlfriend yeah yeah that's my
girlfriend right
and like
and then so like you're you're a seventh
eighth grader you know going on to nine
and then you're just really close and
you're just like yeah we're together
because you're thinking like you're a
fourth grader still you know I remember
in high school knowing like if any girl
that's down to come hang out at my house
it's just like one-on-one like she's
down to be my girlfriend or date or
whatever but that's high school yeah
what are you guys talking about
could you say teenager right
I don't know just young dating
experience it's like it's a rude
awakening yeah the transition period
there are a lot of guys on to adulthood
that I realize do that still do that
yeah of course and I was shocked because
I was like this is what they mean like
the whole friend zone thing right we're
like this guy
he's kind of nerdy he called me up and
he's all like talking about this whole
date with this girl all right and then
hello red flags I was like
this is a date are you sure it's a date
he goes yeah no we're like [__] cool
man I'm like the [__] best bugs dude
to be honest dude I'm like I don't think
she thinks you guys are dating like it
just sounds like she broke up you're a
friend that's her shoulder to cry on
she's hell it's the rebound she just she
just appreciates your company like no I
always drop her off at this dude's house
no for sure
she's slow down yeah at like 1am I drop
her off and then I pick her up at 3am
dude I was like so I was like so I was
like what makes you think like you guys
are a couple like did you guys touch did
you guys kiss like is there is there
movement Romantic Movement yeah and he
goes yeah yeah so there's one time we
were like oh man it was so funny like
she was like not shooting the Target
right so then like I had to adjust it
and then like whenever I was adjusting
her like we did it like this and then we
decided to shoot the gun together and it
was so funny and I'm all like it was so
funny I was like also maybe don't do
that and then I smelled my fingers after
yeah I was like together I was like
that's nothing
like boys could [__] around like that
like that's nothing dude and then he he
couldn't get it through his head so I
was like oh this is how it happens it's
like they're delusional yeah and they
believe that they're in a relationship
when they're not
I'm live on the scene with someone here
who can tell us right away if things
like this still happen today Colleen
they still have it
you know what wait was there a reason
story or something you're trying to
share yeah what happened so this
happened to you has something like this
happened to you this year
what does it always happen to you no you
Heartbreaker no
are you guys talking about some inside
[__] I don't know anything I'm just I'm
wondering
situations where somebody was a friend
and definitely wanted to be more and it
got to a point where it was just like
you're just like hanging around too much
lingerer like did they uh and it was
like literally communicated or you could
feel that
um that's that's the problem was I
clearly communicated hey we are just
friends this will not go any further
yeah it was always just like a a hopeful
like
um maybe she'll turn around but what
about after a shot of Johnny Walker
like you could feel the that he was
pursuing let's just say like even like a
year or two after he sends me this long
like Facebook message about how like
your situation and like how he thought
it was supposed to be something else
that I wasn't and I was just like yo
okay what was your response um I was
just like
I forget what it was called like come on
CE when dudes like they can't read the
situation and they think that this also
specific situation is good to define the
rest of their life I don't know yeah
yeah it sucks man I mean that that
happens dude some guys just get so ahead
of themselves yeah you know what's even
crazier sometimes when you even get past
the stage of touching and having sex and
all all of this stuff where it starts to
feel like you move fast even then even
then they can still turn it around and
say oh I just wanted to have fun I
didn't want to know if they're from UC
Santa Barbara yeah
but that's why if you're gonna be seeing
a girl and you guys are going to be
doing it like you have to know that just
because there's sex and romance and
stuff it doesn't mean you guys are gonna
date what did you agree
I mean I think you should just be open
with it exactly I think both people
should be like you should be clear about
with what you want and communicate and
then but people move the goal posts
though sometimes yeah sometimes but I
think that's just like communication
doesn't just happen once like you have
to continue actually make sure and
that's true because I've seen people get
out of the so-called friend zone yeah
you could do it bro yeah I was in a
friend zone timing yeah situation still
am bro you just gotta be straight up and
tell them what you want and if they
don't want that it's like all right you
have to [__] cut it off I want
pickles and raw onions
most people don't even know what they
want though right so they get in these
like situationships where they're just
it's like that weird gray area that both
people don't know what they want and
then you get those like mixed feelings
and emotions that just translate into
dude you let your feelings speak for you
or you go on yeah you just gotta say it
bro whatever's on your mind just say it
just say it [__] it rip the band that's
actually been the best policy honestly
yeah you're right honestly all the times
yeah yeah I just want to suck on your
titties
okay look I'll do the right context it's
kind of fire bro it kind of it's kind of
nothing but honestly if you have that
report [__] around that is kind of
funny that's true if it's yeah out of
your character yeah dude then it's like
if you're a sweet sweet boy
something
's upset
for 34 years baby
so what do you saying we doing this what
do you say sweetheart I'm just not a
business together what if she responds
in the same way though yeah
you're weird you're weird is it possible
to suck each other's nipples at the same
time that's actually oh [__] no it's not
I didn't never tried it I don't think
it's possible I think you can upside
down yeah like a 69 like this wait what
I I missed the whole first part can you
suck on each other's nipples at the same
time yeah and answer I mean yes or no
yeah yeah you can't answer your head
head yep let's try it
no you perverts We're not gonna show you
that this we're gonna get demonetized
everyone
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign